THE SENATE. EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING. WE HAVE TWO RESOLUTIONS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA. WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A QUORUM. SO WE'LL BEGIN AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND WE DO HAVE
AN AUTHOR FOR THE SECOND OF THE
TWO AMENDMENTS. SO WE'LL TAKE
THESE OUT OF ORDER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARO, WELCOME. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. YOUR
WITNESSES ARE HERE. CORRECT.
PLEASE AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. HCR 211 WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION TO RECOGNIZE CRICKET
AS AN OFFICIAL HIGH SCHOOL
SPORT. CRICKET IS A GAME THAT
ORIGINATED IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
IN THE 19TH CENTURY, AND QUICKLY
SPREAD TO MANY OF ITS FORMER
COLONIES AND NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES, INCLUDING INDIA,
PAKISTAN, AND AUSTRALIA. SINCE
THEN, IT HAS ACHIEVED IMMENSE
POPULARITY, CULTIVATING THRIVING
PLAYER AND FAN COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS THE WORLD. THIS INCLUDES
THE UNITED STATES, WHERE OVER
200,000 PEOPLE PLAY THE GAME.
CALIFORNIA HAS POSITIONED ITSELF
AS ONE OF THE HUBS OF AMERICAN
CRICKET, HOSTING TWO OF THE SIX
MAJOR LEAGUE CRICKET TEAMS AND
PREPARING TO REINTRODUCE CRICKET
AS AN OFFICIAL OLYMPIC SPORT AT
THE UPCOMING 2028 LOS ANGELES
SUMMER OLYMPICS. THE LAST TIME
IT WAS AN OLYMPIC SPORT WAS
1900. CRICKET ALSO HOLDS A
PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE FOR MANY
MEMBERS OF OUR STATE'S SOUTH
ASIAN DIASPORA, CONSIDERED
INTEGRAL TO THEIR HISTORICAL AND
CULTURAL HERITAGE. DESPITE THIS,
CRICKET HAS NOT YET BEEN
RECOGNIZED AS AN OFFICIAL HIGH
SCHOOL SPORT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, DEPRIVING STUDENTS
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN AND
PARTICIPATE IN THIS SPORT. IN
INTER-SCHOOL PLAY. IN RESPONSE,
ACR 211 URGES THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION TO
TAKE STEPS TOWARDS TOWARDS
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZING CRICKET
IF ONE OF ITS MEMBER SCHOOLS
BRINGS IT BEFORE THEM FOR
CONSIDERATION. IT ALSO
EMPHASIZES THAT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF HIGH SCHOOL
CRICKET SHOULD SUPPORT CONTINUED
CRICKET PLAY AT THE COLLEGIATE
LEVEL. ACR 211 NOT ONLY
CELEBRATES CRICKET'S RICH
HISTORY, BUT ENCOURAGES US TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS NEVER, THAT IT
HAS AN EVEN BRIGHTER FUTURE WITH
ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS DAN SAHADEO,
PRESIDENT OF THE DAVIS CRICKET
CLUB. WELCOME, MR. STEREO.
WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
PROMOTING THE SPORT SINCE 1980,
WAS A STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AT THE
TIME, AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THE
ONLY WAY THIS SPORT WILL GROW IN
THIS AREA IS TO HAVE THE YOUTH
PEOPLE PLAYING. WE HAVE
ATTEMPTED MANY TIMES TO TAKE IT
TO THE PE DEPARTMENT, BUT A LOT
OF LOGISTICS INVOLVED IN THAT
AND HOW YOU GET CLEARANCE TO BE
IN A SCHOOL CAMPUS AND SO FORTH.
BUT IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
TRYING WITH BECAUSE IF OUR
YOUTHS CAN BE TAUGHT THE SPORT,
THEN THEY MAY HAVE A CHANCE TO
MAKE THE OLYMPIC TEAM SOMEDAY.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE LEFT OUT AND
LET THE REST OF THE COUNTRY RUN
THE SHOW. SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
WHAT WE HAVE DONE SO FAR AND TO
ASK FOR YOUR HELP GETTING US
GOING FORWARD. VERY GOOD. THANK
YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES PRESENT IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE? SEEING NONE, IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES? YEAH, I HAVE A
COMMENT. SO MY FATHER IN LAW
IMMIGRATED FROM IRAN AND HE
NEVER GRASPED BASEBALL. AND SO.
AND I FEEL THE SAME WAY ABOUT
CRICKET. I MEAN, I'VE KIND OF
SEEN IT, BUT I DON'T KNOW. AND I
KNOW LIKE WORLDWIDE, IT'S A
VERY, VERY POPULAR SPORT. AND I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT. THE ONLY WAY
IT COULD POSSIBLY CATCH ON IS TO
GET IT, TO GET THE YOUTH TO, TO
LEARN ABOUT IT EARLY ON. SO I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT IDEA.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION
TODAY. I APPRECIATE THAT. I TOO
AM GLAD TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
QUORUM. WHEN WE DO, I EXPECT
SENATOR WILK WILL BE GLAD TO
MAKE THE MOTION. I'M HAPPY TO
MAKE THE MOTION. AND WITH THAT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE'LL
TAKE IT UP. AND WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND CLOSE. AND I'M GOING TO LET
HIM CLOSE. ARE YOU GOING TO LET
ME LET HIM CLOSE? SO I WAS HERE.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE, I WANT TO
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND THANK
SENATOR WILK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. I
THINK IT'S A PRIME OPPORTUNITY
WITH CRICKET COMING BACK TO THE
OLYMPICS IN LOS ANGELES IN 2028,
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY SHARE THIS SPORT WITH SO
MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SO THAT
IT CAN REALLY THRIVE AND GROW IN
REALLY THE DECADES AHEAD. I WANT
TO THANK MR. SAHADEO, WHO YOU
KNOW, FOR 44 YEARS HAS BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR CRICKET AND IS,
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE LOCAL
LEADERS HAS REALLY BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT. SO I WANT TO REALLY
APPRECIATE HIS LEADERSHIP. AND
WITH THAT, AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ADVOCACY. AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
BOTH. THANK YOU ALL FOR
LISTENING. VERY GOOD. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. EARLY BIRD
GOT THE WORM. WELCOME WE NOW
MOVE BACK TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
ONE, SR 103 FROM SENATE-TV
PORTANTINO. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, TODAY I PROUDLY PRESENT
SR 103, WHICH WHICH DESIGNATES
THE MONTH OF OCTOBER. AND EVERY
OCTOBER THEREAFTER AS ITALIAN
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. IT ALSO
ENCOURAGES PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO
INCLUDE ITALIAN AMERICAN HISTORY
IN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES AND
OTHER SOCIAL STUDIES COURSES TO
HIGHLIGHT THEIR ACHIEVEMENT AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO, FRANKLY,
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE AND HISTORY.
SR 103 ENCOURAGES TAKING STEPS
TO PROMOTE THE INCLUSION OF
ITALIAN AMERICANS ROLE IN THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR CULTURE,
OUR HISTORY IN BOTH ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY SCHOOL TEXTBOOKS
DURING THE REVISION PROCESS.
AGAIN, IT ENCOURAGES, DOESN'T
REQUIRE TI¾N. AMERICANS WERE
AMONG THE FIRST TO ARRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE GOLD RUSH.
TODAY, THEY ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ETHNIC GROUP IN AMERICA,
NUMBERING ROUGHLY 26 MILLION
PEOPLE, WITH NEARLY 1.5 MILLION
ITALIAN AMERICANS RESIDING IN
CALIFORNIA. A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T
KNOW THAT DURING WORLD WAR TWO,
ITALIAN AMERICANS WERE THE
LARGEST ETHNIC MINORITY TO SERVE
IN THE U.S. ARMED FORCES DURING
WORLD WAR TWO, INCLUDING MY LATE
FATHER, WHO WAS A PROUD ARMY
VETERAN WHO WAS PART OF THAT
WAVE OF ITALIAN SONS AND
DAUGHTERS OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
FOUGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY. WE'VE
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN SHAPING
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND
CULTURE, FROM PIONEERING THE
STATE'S AGRICULTURE AND WINE
INDUSTRIES TO ESTABLISHING THE
FIRST BRANCH BANKING SYSTEM IN
THE U.S. PIONEERS LIKE ANDREA
BARBARO, WHO FOUNDED ITALIAN
SWISS WINE COMPANY IN SONOMA
COUNTY IN 1881, WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN ESTABLISHING THE
WINE INDUSTRY IN THE REALM OF
BANKING. AMADEO PIETRO GIANNINI
FOUNDED THE BANK OF ITALY IN
1904, FOCUSING ON SERVING
EVERYDAY PERSONS RATHER THAN
JUST WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS. THIS
NEW APPROACH TRANSFORMED THE
FINANCIAL INDUSTRY. ITALIAN
AMERICANS HAVE ALSO LEFT AN
INDELIBLE MARK ON THE MOVIE
INDUSTRY, FROM AL PACINO TO
DANNY AIELLO TO MANY DIRECTORS
AND PRODUCERS, THE INFLUENCE IS
EVIDENT IN OUR SUCCESS OF THE
INDUSTRY. OBVIOUSLY, IN THE
REALM OF POLITICS, THIS HOUSE
AND THE ASSEMBLY HAVE BEEN NO
STRANGER TO ITALIAN AMERICANS
LIKE DAVID ROBERTI, DOMINIC
CANNELLA, THE CORTESE FAMILY,
BOTH FATHER AND SON, AS WELL AS
THE FIRST FEMALE SPEAKER OF THE
U.S. CONGRESS, NANCY PELOSI, IS
AN ITALIAN AMERICAN, SO DESPITE
THESE SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS,
FRANKLY, THE ROLE OF ITALIAN
AMERICANS HAS BEEN UNDER TAUGHT
AND IN MY OPINION,
UNDERAPPRECIATED. MANY PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THAT ITALIAN
AMERICANS WERE ACTUALLY INTERNED
DURING WORLD WAR TWO, WHICH MANY
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THAT
HAPPENED. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW
HAPPENED. AND AS I SAID, WE WERE
THE LARGEST ETHNIC MINORITY TO
SERVE IN WORLD WAR TWO, IN SPITE
OF BEING INTERNED DURING THAT
INTERNATIONAL CONFLICT. SO SR
103 HONORS ITALIAN AMERICANS.
LEGACY AND ENCOURAGES SCHOOLS TO
INCLUDE THOSE ACHIEVEMENTS IN
HISTORY AND SOCIAL STUDIES. AND
WITH ME, I HAVE BILL CERUTI, WHO
WILL OFFER SOME EXPERT TESTIMONY
AS A MEMBER OF SEVERAL ITALIAN
AMERICAN TASK FORCE AND THE
LOCAL ITALIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. SO THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU, SIR.
MR. LU█T WELCOME. THANK YOU. IS
THIS WORKING? YES. THANK YOU.
YEAH MY NAME IS BILL CERUTI. I'M
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ITALIAN AMERICAN TASK FORCE,
WHICH IS A STATE COMMISSION THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED TO REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF ITALIAN AMERICANS
AT THE AT THE STATE LEVEL. AND
THE TASK FORCE PRIMARILY.
PRIMARY GOALS ARE EDUCATIONAL,
OUR SINGULAR PRIMARY GOAL IS TO
INCLUDE ITALIAN AMERICANS IN THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CURRICULUM. WE
HAVE NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL. WE'VE
HAD SEVERAL BILLS PASSED THROUGH
BOTH HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK, AND
NEITHER ONE MADE A SIGNATURE.
SO, WE'VE BEEN VERY FRUSTRATED
BY THAT. WE HOPE THAT THIS
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL SUPPORT
FUTURE EFFORTS, TO INCLUDE
ITALIAN AMERICANS IN THE SCHOOL
STUDIES THAT, CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE EXPOSED TO. WE FEEL
THAT WE DID A MAJOR TEXTBOOK
STUDY, AT FOR HIGH SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES IN THE PAST THAT FOUND
THAT THERE WAS NO MENTION OF
ITALIAN AMERICANS IN ANY OF
THEM, JUST BARELY. THERE WAS A
FEW REFERENCES TO AL CAPONE, BUT
BEYOND THAT, WE WEREN'T IN THE
TEXTBOOKS AS FAR AS WORLD WAR
TWO. MY OWN GRANDFATHER WAS A
HAD A CONTRACT WITH THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO TO HAUL GARBAGE,
AND THEY TOOK AWAY HIS CONTRACT
BECAUSE HE WAS NOT AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, ALTHOUGH HE WAS A LEGAL
RESIDENT SINCE THE 1890S. IN
CALIFORNIA, HE LOST HIS
LIVELIHOOD AND NEVER RECOVERED.
NOR DID MY FAMILY. BUT THAT'S
JUST, ONE OF THE PAINFUL
CHAPTERS IN OUR HISTORY THERE.
THERE ARE SEVERAL. THE MASS
LYNCHING OF ITALIANS IN NEW
ORLEANS LED TO THE CREATION OF
COLUMBUS DAY HOLIDAY, WHICH IS
SACRED IN THE ITALIAN COMMUNITY.
AND, FAIRLY POLITICIZED RIGHT
NOW. BUT WE'RE WE'RE DOING OUR
BEST TO KEEP IT. ANYWAY, I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPLAIN THAT THE ITALIAN
AMERICANS CAME TO CALIFORNIA
WITH THE GOLD RUSH, ONE OF THE
LARGEST GROUPS THAT CAME IN THE
1850S. WE WERE ONE OF THE
LARGEST GROUPS IN THE MINES OF
SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN. I ASK YOU
TO FINISH UP, SIR. PARDON TO
FINISH UP. OH, SORRY. IN
CONCLUSION, WE'VE BEEN HERE
SINCE THE 1850S, WE'RE WE'RE
VERY ESTABLISHED POPULATION, AND
WE HAVE REALLY PROVEN THIS
RESOLUTION WHICH HIGHLIGHTS OUR
CONTRIBUTIONS. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
BEING SUCH A SOLID ADVOCATE FOR
THIS EFFORT, DO WE HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE SEEING
NONE, DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE
COMING BACK TO THE DAIS? TO MY
COLLEAGUE. I JUST WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION. SO I'VE NEVER HEARD
ABOUT ITALIAN AMERICANS BEING
INTERNED. HOW MANY AND WHERE
WERE THEY INTERNED? SO THERE'S A
BOOK CALLED SUNSHINE AND
STRUGGLE, WHICH I'LL GET YOU A
COPY OF, WHICH DETAILS THE
INTERNMENT, THE INTERNMENT? I
WANT TO SAY, WAS IT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MØT? WELL THE WORST
PART ABOUT THAT PERIOD WAS THAT
10,000 ITALIAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA WERE FORCED TO
RELOCATE FROM THE WEST COAST.
THE FBI KNOCKED ON THEIR DOORS
AND SAID LEAVE. AND THEY WERE
FORCED TO LEAVE, AND THEY HAD
NOWHERE TO GO. WE HAD 90 YEAR
OLD GRANDMOTHERS LIVING IN
CHICKEN COOPS. THEY WERE NOT
ALLOWED ON THE WESTERN. EVEN JOE
DIMAGGIO'S FATHER COULD NOT
VISIT HIS SON'S RESTAURANT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AT THAT TIME. I'LL
GET YOU A COPY OF THE BOOK. IT'S
CALLED SUNSHINE AND STRUGGLE.
YEAH, I'D BE REALLY INTERESTED
IN THAT. THANK YOU. NOW, JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT, NO, WE DON'T
HAVE A THIRD VOTE, SO I WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR IT IF THAT'S IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU. YES.
THAT'S TRUE. WE GOT SOME TIME.
WE GOT TIME. SO REGALE US WITH
STORIES PLEASE. SO IN THE YEAR
2000, FOR 60 YEARS, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DENIED THOSE EVENTS
HAPPENED. HUNDREDS OF ITALIAN
AMERICANS WERE INTERNED FOR THE
DURATION OF THE WAR, MOSTLY IN
MISSOULA, MONTANA. FOR 60 YEARS.
THE GOVERNMENT DENIED FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DENIED. THESE EVENTS
HAPPENED, BUT OUR SCHOLARS ON
THE WEST COAST PUT TOGETHER THE
STORY, WENT TO CONGRESS IN THE
YEAR 2000, BILL CLINTON SIGNED
THE ITALIAN AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT, WHICH RECOGNIZED
THOSE EVENTS AND ORDERED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION. THE REPORT WAS
ISSUED, WHICH VERIFIED ALL THE
FACTS SO, THOUSANDS WERE
IMPRISONED. YOU REMEMBER WE GOT
A KNOCK ON THE DOOR AT MIDNIGHT
AND WE WERE HAULED OUT OF OUR
OUR HOMES AND PUT IN FRONT OF
PEOPLE QUESTIONING OUR LOYALTY.
MANY OF OUR ELDER ITALIANS
COMMITTED SUICIDE. THEY WERE
AMERICANS, AND THEY COULDN'T
BELIEVE THEY WERE. LOYALTY WAS
QUESTIONED AND THEY ACTUALLY
COMMITTED SUICIDE. LET ME
WELCOME A GREAT ITALIAN AMERICAN
HERE. SENATOR CORTESE, GOOD
MORNING, WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF,
I'M GOING TO I'M GOING TO LET
HIM MAKE THE MOTION, BUT WE
STILL DON'T. THIS IS A SEVEN
MEMBER COMMITTEE, CORRECT. SO
THIS GETS US TO THREE. SO WE
STILL HAVE MORE TIME. SO PLEASE
CONTINUE. SO IF I COULD ADD REAL
QUICK THERE, MR. WILK ON THIS,
MR. WILK, THERE'S A VERY FAMOUS,
CARTOON THAT WAS IN THE NEW YORK
NEWSPAPERS AT THE TIME, AND IT
HAD AN EXAGGERATION OF A SHIP IN
THE PORT. AND THEN THE, THE ROPE
THAT THE SHIP WAS TIED ON THE
DOCK AND ON THE ROPE WERE RATS,
AND ONE WAS NAMED VITO, ONE WAS
NAMED ANGELO AND MARCO. THEY
WERE. SO WE WERE CONSIDERED THE
RATS LEAVING THE SHIP. AND THAT
WAS LITERALLY PUBLISHED IN A
REPUTABLE NEW YORK NEWSPAPER AT
THE TIME TO SORT OF COMMENT ON
WHAT PEOPLE THOUGHT OF ITALIAN
AMERICANS COMING TO, TO, TO THIS
COUNTRY AT THE TIME, WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE HERE. AND BY THE WAY,
MR. CORTESE, I MENTIONED YOUR
FAMILY'S LEGACY AND YOU MISSED
THE GOOD STUFF, BUT YOUR BUT
YOU'RE HERE ALSO ON TAPE IS A IS
A FIRM COMMITMENT BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO TO GIVE SENATOR
WICKER A BOOK. YES, IT'S ON THE
RECORD. SUNSHINE AND STRUGGLES,
SUNSHINE AND STRUGGLE. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, WE STILL DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM, SO WE CAN DO THIS ONE
OF TWO WAYS. WE CAN EITHER, YOU
KNOW, HOLD OFF OR IF YOU'VE GOT
OTHER INFORMATION. MR. SORRY I
CUT YOU OFF BECAUSE GENERALLY WE
GIVE TWO MINUTES TO EACH
WITNESS, BUT IF YOU'VE GOT
ANYTHING ELSE, YOU'D LIKE TO
ADD, BY ALL MEANS, EDUCATE US.
SENATOR CORTESE. GO AHEAD. FIRST
OF ALL, I'M SORRY. SORRY I'M A
FEW MINUTES LATE COMING IN, BUT
SINCE THERE APPEARS TO BE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME HERE, I JUST
WANTED TO THANK SENATOR
PORTENTINO FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. I
MEAN, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HOWEVER MANY OR FEW ITALIAN
AMERICANS WE HAVE IN THE
LEGISLATURE, YOU KNOW, REALLY
SHOULD BE TOP OF MIND. AND WHEN
HE SAID IT TO ME TO LET ME KNOW
THAT THIS WAS COMING AND,
SUGGESTED THAT I COAUTHOR AND
I'M A PROUD COAUTHOR, HONESTLY,
MY FIRST, NOTE TO SELF WAS, YOU
KNOW, THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN TOP
OF MIND FOR ME AS WELL. SO THANK
HIM FOR HIS AWARENESS AND BEING
ASTUTE ABOUT THIS. AND I DID
CATCH SOME OF THE TESTIMONY
ABOUT WHAT'S CALLED LA STORIA
SEGRETA THE SECRET STORY. AND
IT'S CALLED THAT BECAUSE THERE'S
JUST BEEN SO LITTLE INFORMATION
OR EDUCATION ABOUT HOW ITALIAN
AMERICANS WERE TREATED DURING
WORLD WAR TWO, NOT JUST THOSE
THAT WERE INTERNED, BUT THOSE
WHO WERE PUT UNDER SEVERE CURFEW
SEPARATE AND APART FROM, YOU
KNOW, OTHER AMERICANS AT THE
TIME, INCLUDING RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING IN MY
HOMETOWN, WHERE THERE WERE HUGE
NUMBERS OF DIASPORA AT THE TIME.
AND I KNOW YOU'VE COVERED THIS
GROUND, BUT I JUST WANTED TO
INDICATE THAT IT'S, YOU KNOW,
DEEP SEATED WITH ME. AND I THINK,
AS THE CHAIR KNOWS, BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD RELATED ISSUES COME UP
IN PREVIOUS POLICY COMMITTEE
MEETINGS, YOU KNOW, THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY
WITH CERTAIN ETHNIC GROUPS. I
HAVEN'T HESITATED TO AT LEAST
MENTION, YOU KNOW, MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN, I DON'T WANT TO,
IMPUTE THIS MY, YOU KNOW, MY AGE
OR MY TIME ON THIS EARTH, ON
ANYONE ELSE, INCLUDING SENATOR
PORTENTINO. BUT I'M OLD ENOUGH
TO HAVE EXPERIENCED THOSE DIRECT
SLURS AND INSULTS, YOU KNOW, ON
THE PLAYGROUND AND EVERYWHERE
ELSE RIGHT HERE. AND WE ALWAYS
SAY RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
HOW COULD THAT OCCUR? YOU KNOW,
AND THE MOVIE NOT HERE TO DO A
MOVIE, A PLUG FOR SOMEBODY'S
FILM THAT'S TRYING TO MAKE
MONEY. I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER, BUT THE MOVIE
THAT'S OUT AND I THINK AVAILABLE
BY STREAM NOW, CABRINI IS FOR
ITALIAN AMERICANS. IT'S AN
EXTRAORDINARILY PAINFUL BUT
ACCURATE DEPICTION OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN NEW YORK AT THAT
TIME. AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO WATCH IT FOR THE
ENTERTAINMENT VALUE. BUT ALSO,
YOU KNOW, FOR THE HISTORY
LESSON, BECAUSE I JUST THINK
EITHER MUCH OF THAT HAS REMAINED
A SECRET AND OR, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE JUST AREN'T AWARE IT'S
BEEN GENERATIONS NOW. AND
FORTUNATELY, MUCH ASSIMILATION
HAS OCCURRED OVER THE YEARS. SO
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE AS AN
ITALIAN AMERICAN IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND PROUD TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH SENATOR
PORTENTINO ON THIS ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I MEAN, I'LL SAY WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR A FOURTH. I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT,
SENATOR CORTEZ'S FATHER WAS THE
ORIGINAL CHAIR OF OUR TASK
FORCE. THAT WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ITS CREATION. THAT'S ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, VERY
INTERESTING. SO I I'LL SAY I
MEAN, SENATOR CORTEZ'S POINT,
THIS THIS CONVERSATION, THIS
RESOLUTION INTERSECTS WITH A
LARGER CONVERSATION ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES AND TO, THE POINT OF AT
LEAST ONE PART OF THIS
RESOLUTION, THE STORY OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE INCOMPLETE
WITHOUT TELLING THE STORY OF THE
DISTINCTIVE CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
HISTORY AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STATE OF THE NATION, OF NOT ONLY
ITALIAN AMERICANS, BUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. RIGHT. SO I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE BROADER INTENT OF THE
ETHNIC STUDIES EFFORT. AND I
GUESS WITH THAT, IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE, WE'RE PROBABLY GETTING
CLOSE TO A QUORUM HERE. I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM GAVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A WE SHOULD
DO THIS MORE OFTEN. EXACTLY. I
ACTUALLY HAVE DETAILED, ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IMPORTANT
ASPECTS OF HISTORY, AND I THINK,
YOU KNOW, THE FACT THAT SOME OF
YOU DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT THE PLIGHT
OF ITALIAN AMERICANS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO, YOU KNOW, AS A
BODY, YOU KNOW, EMPHASIZES WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TELL ALL OF
HISTORY AND TO TELL IT
ACCURATELY AND TO BE INCLUSIVE
IN HOW WE DO THAT. SO I
APPRECIATE MR. CERRUTI'S EFFORTS
FOR HIS ENTIRE LIFE TO PROMOTE
ITALIAN AMERICAN HISTORY AND
CULTURE. AND MR. CORTESE AND HIS
FAMILY LEGACY, BEING A BIG PART
OF THAT AS WELL. AND WITH THAT,
WHEN APPROPRIATE, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GLAD TO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU, MR. CHARITY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY,
WITH THAT, WE WILL RECESS FOR
THE TIME BEING AS WE WAIT FOR A
FOURTH MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND WE
HAVE A FOURTH MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE HERE. SO WELCOME,
SENATOR, LET US NOW, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE NEED A MOTION. NO, WE DON'T.
WE NEED A QUORUM. NEWMAN. HERE.
NEWMAN HERE. OCHOA. BOGH HERE.
OCHOA HERE. CORTESE. CORTESE.
HERE GLAZER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. PRESENT. WILK
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS NOW PRESENT,
I'M LOOKING FOR A MOTION ON THE
FIRST OF THE TWO ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. SR 103, WHERE THEY ARE
PRESENTED OR IN THE FILE ORDER.
IN THE FILE ORDER, PLEASE. I
DEFER TO SENATOR CORTESE. YOU
ARE 103. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION. MADAM PRESIDENT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL. ITEM ONE SR
103 PORTANTINO. MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED IN ORDER TO THIRD
READING. NEWMAN A, NEWMAN I
OKOBO OCHOA I CORTESE A, CORTESE
I GLASER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK WILK I. THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES. I WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR NOW. AND THE
SECOND OF THE TWO MEASURES,
NUMBER TWO S.C.R. 211. SENATOR,
I'D LIKE TO HONOR MY COMMITMENT
THAT I MADE TO THE AUTHOR AND
MOVE, MOVE THE RESOLUTION. I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSISTENCY, WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WELL ITEM
TWO HCR 211, CALL FOR MOTION TO
BE ADOPTED IN ORDER TO THIRD
READING. NEWMAN NEWMAN I OCHOA I
OKOBOJI. CORTESE. CORTESE I.
GLASER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILK I WILK I. VERY
GOOD. I'M GOING TO GIVE EXACTLY
FIVE MINUTES FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS TO APPEAR AND WEIGH IN
ON THESE TWO MEASURES, BUT THANK
YOU TO THE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE,
AND WE'LL RECESS FOR NOW.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF GIVING ONE
MORE CHANCE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
TO COME THROUGH THAT DOOR,
SEEING NO OPENING DOOR, WE WILL
THEN CLOSE THE ROLL, AND EACH OF
THE MEASURES IS OUT BY VOTES OF
4 TO 0, AND WITH THAT, THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION IS
ADJOURNED.